it's estimated that somebody escapes
extreme poverty every 1.2 seconds
[Music]
according to the World Bank anyone on
less than $1 90 per day is living in
extreme poverty unable to afford basic
food clothing health care and shelter
absolute poverty rates have fallen
faster in the past 30 years than in any
other time on record this is a
remarkable achievement but the task of
taking people out of the worst poverty
remains a huge challenge
the impressive fall is the result of
changes in just two countries China and
India in the 1980s the majority of
people in both of these countries were
living in extreme poverty
but now the share of the poorest has
fallen to 21% in India and less than 2%
in China
[Music]
increased productivity in farms and a
mass migration from poor rural areas to
the booming cities enabled many Chinese
and Indian people to better their lives
[Music]
Asia is moving into a new phase but can
other parts of the world copy their
model of moving people to factory jobs
in cities today more than half the
world's poorest people live in
sub-saharan Africa the percentage of the
African population living in extreme
poverty fell from 54% in 1990 to 41% in
2013 but in that same time period the
population of sub-saharan Africa boomed
meaning the total number of poor people
rose from 276 million to almost 400
million the population of sub-saharan
Africa is predicted to reach 2 billion
by 2050 and a large percentage of those
people are likely to be extremely poor
and unlike Asia a transformation of this
region is unlikely to happen soon
sub-saharan Africa is urbanizing faster
than any other place on earth but moving
into the cities is not providing the
same ladder out of poverty as it did in
Asia a lack of infrastructure of public
transport and essential services in many
African cities prevents poor people from
finding jobs and getting an education
the rapidly growing population only
makes matters worse by putting further
strain on resources millions of poor
people in sub-saharan Africa live far
below the World Bank's threshold of $1
90 per day that means it'll be harder to
pull them out of extreme poverty
you
[Music]